dernière fois elle nous disait vraiment
qu'elle pouvait compter sur vous tout le
temps alban bartoli mercier le bond est
là merci alors on vous connaît pas ce
que vous avez fait chanteur avant oui
bien entendu et vous avez enquêté sur
sylvie ortega alors enquêté c'est un
bien grand mot puisque sylvie ortega m'a
fourni les preuves de sa malveillance
sur un plateau d'argent
donc c'est un peu c'est un idée marc
direct un bail honnêtement d'ailleurs je
tiens à te préciser je te remercie pour
toutes les phrases que tu as fait
aujourd'hui sur les réseaux sociaux
tu as bien tu vas bien vu tu l'a bien vu
que je n'ai absolument pas répondu
puisque je voulais qu'ils répondent ici
alors alors s'il vous plaît on va on va
revenir là dessus sylvie déjà comme en
valois n'a pas ce que vous avez eu de
ses nouvelles
bien sûr je vais l'appeler quatre fois
aujourd'hui j'ai lu policiers avec des
heures les dates et tous aujourd'hui
j'ai eu quatre fois au téléphone
loana ne connais absolument pas la
personne que j'ai en face de moi donc
également qu'ils triaient son petit chat
mais bon je fais mon procès genre je ne
savais pas qu alban étaient programm
s'il vous plaît pour les téléspectateurs
mal ben qu'est ce que vous reprochez à
6,8 alors juste je réponds 30 secondes
évidemment que loana me connaît puisque
j'ai partagé en 2017 le plateau des
interviews sont en stock people j'ai les
preuves tout c'est sur youtube on a
partagé nommément de soirée caritative
ensemble donc évidemment je ne suis
peut-être pas autant légitime que vous
qui la connaissait beaucoup plus puisque
je ne me prétends pas amie de loana
juste est quelqu'un qui a croisé ma
route très régulièrement et a pour qui
j'ai énormément d'affection
il y alors ce que je reproche à 6,8
égard tout simplement je j'anime une
émission qui s'appelle ils ont fait la
une
j'ai vu chez vous que loana était venu
jeu elle m'a beaucoup touché j'ai voulu
la recevoir sur mon émission évidemment
moi je n'avais rien contre toi au début
tu sais on sait déjà croisé à cannes le
le fait que tu reçois un petit peu
perché etc moi je n'ai rien contre toi
en revanche en revanche quand j'ai
adressé du coup une note vocale tout à
fait cordiale et je n'ai pas dit bonjour
ma sylvie j'ai les notes vocales un an
preuve je les ai en capture quand je me
suis adressé à ses 10 pour la faire
venir dans mon émission
s'il y aurait gamma complètement choqué
avec ses notes vocales
alors en fait elle a clairement mis la
couverture sur elles dès le début en me
disant que loana bon était évidemment
faible en ce moment qu'elle prenait des
cachets et c'est donc évidemment je ne
peux pas aller contre ça mais en
revanche tu as tout de suite dit par
contre je suis extrêmement choquée que
vous mais éveillé jamais invité dans
votre ennemi alors c'est toi si tu sais
en langue mais c'est toi qui tu es
quelqu'un de décerner les cernant je
suis raide on avait cette ville évitant
un message d'alerté avait jugé ya déjà
les doigts qu'est ce que vous répondez
aux à ceux qui vous accusent d'être une
mauvaise fréquentation pour loire
soutient on ne m'accuse pas l'être une
mauvaise note à dix jours du monde tu
m'accuses fréquentation je t'ai laissé
parler tu me laisses pas l'orientation
je t'en prie fait d'accord benghazi
voilà alors si tu déjà de une on me dis
pas que je suis mauvaise fréquentation
me traite carrément de criminels c'est
vrai c'est pas mais c'est vrai qu'il
vous plaît s'il te plaît 2010 alors donc
qui sont ces gens pour moi qu'ils auront
démontré de tenir thuel pour ne traiter
de criminels et de faire mon procès
alors justement guillaume pourquoi
encore sylvie de criminels pour les
téléspectateurs puisque certaines
personnes disent qu'ils auraient une
mauvaise influence sur le nam moi je
prends pas parti je voudrais juste dire
une chose c'est que quand on voit tous
les articles lohan est entre la vie et
la mort et c'est un raccourci qui est
très facile à faire c'est trouver des
coupables en fait instantanément dire
c'est la faute de sylvie c'est la faute
de la télé c'est notre faute à nous
parce qu'on fait un documentaire
je voudrais juste dire que loana on
s'intéresse elle pas parce qu'elle va
mal parce que c'est les 20 ans du loft
une date anniversaire bien sûr donc nous
on est là pour la traiter de manière
bienveillante ont fait un documentaire
sur elle comme on en a fait sur jean
pierre pernaut on a fait surtout plein
de gens on la traite avec bienveillance
n'est pas là pour la tirer vers le bas
le principe du documentaire c'est de
l'emmener sur les endroits qui ont
marqué sa vie on était dans le sud de la
france avec elle donc arrêté et j'ai
franchement rien contre vous je vous
connais pas si bien que ça je arrêter
devoir trouver des coupables
instantanément la situation de l'ona
elle est très compliqué ça fait dix
années que c'est compliqué le love
s'était ya 20 ans donc voilà je pense
qu'il faut arrêter de trouver des
coupables et laisser les gens qui ont
mangé
m